Will you please make the voter say for our Eastern listeners, good evening, radio audience. And now for our Western listeners, say good afternoon, radio audience.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express Ausgabe Nr. 109. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zu einer neuen Sendung rund um Computer und die Welt und die Gesellschaft und die Technik und überhaupt und all diese ganzen Details, die eigentlich immer keinen interessieren, außer uns. Uns beide, die wir hier im Studio sind und natürlich euch, die Hörer. Uns ist heute neben mir der Lars, Lars Immisch, hallo.
Hallo Tim.
Und wir haben uns hier zusammengefunden, um ein Thema aufzurollen, was wir, wie wir jetzt auch gerade wieder in der Vorbesprechung festgestellt haben, irgendwie unter dem Radar ist, auf eine ganz merkwürdige Art und Weise.
Es ist auch ein Schmuddelkind, man muss es ja auch zugeben.
Die Rede ist von CTI oder auch Computer-Telefonie-Integration. Wir wollen also reden über den Teil der Technik, wo Computer auf das Telefonnetz treffen. Und zwar nicht so, wie das in den Ursprungszeiten mal war, dass der Computer das Telefonnetz quasi nur als Internetersatz verwendet zur Datenübertragung oder als Zugang zum Internet. Das ist glaube ich so die Hauptanwendung gewesen. Je nachdem, da können wir auf jeden Fall noch mal drüber reden. Sondern es geht eher um die andere Geschichte, wo der Computer das Telefonnetz als solches verwendet, also Sprache behandelt. Das ist jetzt grob gesagt der Rahmen. Und ich habe den Lars gebeten, zu diesem Thema sich hier mal kundig zu äußern, wir haben ja früher gemeinsam an solchen Projekten gearbeitet, genau, eigentlich nur eins. Was wir hier weder in den Vordergrund stellen wollen, noch unnötig ausblenden, die Villa, ein spaßiges Projekt, das wir zusammen gemacht haben, wo wir dann beide eigentlich zu diesem Thema gekommen sind. Du bist dann hängen geblieben.
Genau, ich bin da hängen geblieben, das ist auch relativ fürchterlich. Aber es interessiert mich natürlich auch, auch dieser Aspekt, man kann auf einem Telefon, auf einer fremden Device, ein rotes Knöpfchen irgendwie zum Leuchten bringen, das finde ich ganz toll.
Ja, ich fand das auch toll. Vor allem fand ich diesen Aspekt toll, damals, also damals ist Anfang der 90er-Jahre, damals so zu behaupten, man hätte es mit dem größten Netzwerk der Welt zu tun. Weil alle so ein bisschen mit den Augen gerollt haben, was kann das wohl sein? Und was sich halt viele Leute nicht so klar gemacht haben, weil das auch schon so allgegenwärtig war, ist einfach, dass das Telefonnetz eben genau das ist, ist einfach die größte Netzwerkinstallation. Ob sie heute noch als solche gelten kann, da bin ich mir schon fast nicht mehr so sicher, sie geht ja jetzt auch eher in den Computernetzen auf.
Ja, sie verschwindet.
Sie verschwindet, aber damals war das auf jeden Fall State of the Art. Nur Computer und Telefon zusammenzubringen, war nicht so einfach.
Das hat ich, wie gesagt, die Anfangszeiten habe ich nicht mitbekommen. Also so richtig populär wurde, dass glaube ich durch diese Big Mouth Karte, die es auch immer noch zu kaufen gibt, das ist eine ESA-Karte, die gibt es immer noch zu kaufen. Ja, wenn du Big Mouth eingibst, Big Mouth war in der Tat, glaube ich, auch nur der Applikationsgenerator dafür. Und Big Mouth, der lief, glaube ich, dann unter DOS 3, keine Ahnung. Und die Karte, die dazugehörte, das war eine ESA-Karte mit einem Kanal analogem Potsplain-Old-Telefonie-System-Anschluss. Und da konnte man sich dann seine lustigen Anrufbeantworten und menügesteuerten Chatboxen zusammen basteln. Da musste dann, da das nur eine Leitung zur Zeit war, konnte man sich da zum Beispiel schon mal so geteilte Anrufbeantworte implementieren. Der eine ruft an, hinterlässt eine Nachricht an alle. Der nächste ruft an, hört sich das an, weil er sich langweilt. Damals gab es doch kein Internet, es gab nur Fernsehen und Telefon. Das darf man ja auch nicht vergessen. Ruft dann an, hört sich das an und hinterlässt dann wieder eine Nachricht. Und das haben die Leute wirklich relativ begeistert benutzt. Und aus diesem Hintergrund ist ja auch damals die Villa entstanden. Dass man gesagt hat, oh, wir müssen das unbedingt irgendwie mit mindestens 120 Leitungen gleichzeitig machen und wir brauchen Conferencing und wir wollen lustige Sachen machen und eigentlich eine Game-Engine haben und gar nicht so was menügesteuert ist. Wir wollen richtig virtuelle Welten haben. Wir wollen richtig Audio-Reality haben.
Aber vielleicht blicken wir vorher noch mal kurz darauf, wie sich das Telefonnetz eigentlich bis dahin entwickelt hat, bis die Computer kamen. Anfang der 80er Jahre, kann man sagen, war eigentlich das Telefonnetz weltweit weitgehend ein analoges Netz, d.h. es wurden wirklich Leitungsverbindungen hergestellt, end zu end. Und dann gab es halt diese schleichende Digitalisierung, die in Deutschland relativ fix voran ging, mit ISDN. Also ISDN ist in gewisser Hinsicht wahrscheinlich auch schon der zweite Schritt gewesen, weil sich dann das Digitale ja auf den Backbones durchgesetzt hat, plus mit ISDN schlugs dann das erste Mal zu Hause auf.
Genau, das Digitale kam, soweit ich das erinnere, wirklich aus den Backbones. Da ging es ganz einfach darum, aus einer gegebenen Kupferstrecke so viel Bandbreite rauszuholen wie möglich und man wollte das nicht weitermachen, dass man die Frequenzbänder übereinander gelegt hat, sondern man wollte das dann gleich digitalisieren. Das war, glaube ich, T1-Robbit, das sind Patente von Bell Labs von 1964. Soweit ich weiß, ja. Also da kommt grundsätzlich dieses T1 her und das ist dann verfeinert worden. T1 ist ein unglaublich primitives Protokoll, das überträgt die Signalisierungsinformation im normalen Datenstrom, d.h. Robbit-Signaling, weil man jedes zweite, achte Bit klaut und damit sagt On-Hook oder Off-Hook. Und dass dann irgendwie das Sample, das ja eigentlich Audioinformation auch enthält, dann plötzlich nur noch 7 Bit enthalten kann und nicht mehr 8 Bit, das war einem einfach völlig egal damals.
Da kommen auch diese krummen Megabit-Zahlen, die man mit T1 usw. so 1,5 und so, was man ja eigentlich überhaupt nicht gewohnt ist, wenn man mit Computern was zu tun hat. Ganz genau, da kommt das her. Ich meine, ich kann mich da noch erinnern, als das mit ISDN, wann kamen eigentlich diese ISDN-Karten auf?
Das muss in den fräten 80er gewesen sein oder die frühen 90er.
War das schon so? Hatten wir da damals schon welche?
Du meinst jetzt Fritz-Karten?
Fritz ist glaube ich jetzt ein Produkt, was ein bisschen später kam, aber es gab ja auch andere Anbieter, aber es muss auch so Anfang der 90er-Jahre losgegangen sein.
Ja, das waren aber dann schon die 90er-Jahre, dass sich das so weit durchgesetzt hatte, dass das wirklich zu Endverbrauch angekommen ist.
Aber jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie hat sich denn jetzt sozusagen das Telefonnetz erstmal dem Digitalen entgegengestreckt? Also, wenn man jetzt alles nicht mehr analog macht, meine Vorhersprache ist klar, die Sprache wird einfach direkt in Spannung moduliert und die wird dann irgendwie halt übertragen. Aber das Signaling selber, also der Aufbau, der Rufaufbau, vielleicht kannst du damit ja mal losgehen.
Du spannst den Bogen ein bisschen weiter, das ist schwierig. Also, ich denke, was zuerst kam, war die Digitalisierung wirklich des Kernnetzwerks und da läuft aber definitiv nicht ISDN, das darf man immer nicht denken, da läuft SS7, Signaling System 7. Das ist von der ITU standardisiert worden. Das ist ein Protokoll-Stack, der wirklich etwa so umfangreich ist wie IP inklusive dem Applikations-Layer. Da sind also wirklich Applikations-Protokolle drin enthalten in TCP, Applikations-Naheprotokolle enthalten in SS7, die normalerweise so etwa auf der Ebene von HTTP sich bewegen.
Darauf brauchen wir auch nicht einzugehen.
Was danach kam, nachdem der Kern des Netzwerks digitalisiert worden war, ist man dann dazu übergegangen, die last mile, also das letzte Stück Draht zwischen der Vermittlungsstelle und dem Kunden, dem Customer, zu digitalisieren und hat dafür ein neues, tatsächlich wirklich ein neues Protokoll erfunden, ISDN. Und da gibt es verschiedene Protokollvarianten, da gibt es eine ganze Protokollfamilie. In Deutschland hat man angefangen mit einem selbstgestrickten Protokoll, das hieß 1TR6. Das hat man dann im Rahmen der europäischen Vereinheitlichung auf Euro-ISDN umgestellt. Und heutzutage wird in Deutschland nur noch Euro-ISDN benutzt. Das basiert im Wesentlichen auf dem Q931-Standard. Der ist für einen Telefoniestandard wirklich ziemlich knackig. Das sind irgendwie so 90 Seiten. Und wenn man ein bisschen Geduld hat, kann man den wirklich lesen, ohne dass man dabei stirbt. Der ist relativ simpel, der beschreibt einen Paketaufbau. Da steht dann drin, wie wird die Calling-Party-Number übertragen? Was wird dann noch übertragen? In welchem Netz ist das? Was für ein Numbering-Plan ist das? Und wie werden die Digits überhaupt codiert? Und das kann man wirklich lesen, das ist völlig self-contained. Und wenn ein Ruf aufgebaut wird, dann wird in dem Fall, das war glaube ich auch deine Frage, ein Setup geschickt und dann kommt ein Proceeding vom ersten Switch oder vom letzten Switch. Ja, okay, ich habe das bekommen, ich leite das jetzt weiter und dann kommt ein Alerting. Das heißt tatsächlich, das andere Telefon, das ich gerade versuche anzurufen, das klingelt jetzt. Und dann kommt ein Call Connected. Das ist glaube ich ein Connect-Paket, genau.
Ja, und dann geht es ja eigentlich erst los mit der Sprache. Wir wollen ja eigentlich auf die Sprache hinaus. Ich habe mich ein bisschen ungeschickt ausgedrückt, glaube ich. Aber was ich meinte ist, wie wird denn jetzt die Sprache im digitalen Netz repräsentiert? Also welche Art von Digitalisierung hat jetzt die Sprache selber erfahren?
Die Sprache wird Pulse Code Modulated übertragen, also PCM. Das heißt, man teilt sich eine Sekunde in 8000 kleine Fensterchen ein und in jedem Fensterchen guckt man sich, wo ist denn gerade meine Wellenform? Ist die oben, ist die unten, ist die weit oben, ist die weit unten? Sampelt diesen Wert, also ermittelt den analogen Wert, das sind 12 Bit in dem Fall, die überhaupt gesampelt werden, also von minus irgendwas bis plus irgendwas, und davon werden 8000 in der Sekunde übertragen. Und diese 12 Bit werden nochmal mit einem logarithmischen Komprimierungsverfahren abgebildet auf 8 Bit, dass man lautere Lautstärkeunterschiede weniger stark abbildet oder stärker abbildet als kleine Lautstärkeunterschiede. Und dann hat man irgendwie 8 Bit, 8000 Werte, und da ist man bei 64 Kilobit, und das ist genau ein IS, der NB-Kanal.
Also, was jetzt die Lauteren werden komprimiert oder die...
Oh, da darfst du mich nicht fragen. Das ist physioakustisch, das ist irgendwie...
Klingt nach einem...
Psychoakustik ist das. Das ist psychoakustisch, das habe ich vergessen. Könnte man nachgucken. Also, da steht ALR oder Müller, gibt es zwei verschiedene Standards. Einen in Amerika, einen hier, wir benutzen ALR, die Amerikaner, und die meisten anderen benutzen Müller.
Ja, vermute man, dass es sich ja einfach um eine Kompression handelt, dass man das halt einfach zeigt.
Ja, das ist wirklich eine Abbildung des Lautstärkers.
Aber diese ALR und Müller-Geschichte, die ist auch immer noch unterschiedlich.
Ja, die sind einfach beide da und existieren. Nimmt ja der einen dem anderen keinen Kontakt.
Wie incompatibel ist denn die amerikanische und die europäische Sichtweise? Und was hat der Rest der Welt gemacht? Machen wieder alle europäisch?
Der Rest der Welt hat natürlich eine Münze geworfen und sich dann je nachdem entschieden. Aber das ist praktisch überhaupt kein Problem. Das ist einfach ein Non-Issue. Das trifft nur ab und zu irgendwelche Leute, die denken, es gibt nur ihr Kodierungsverfahren, kommen in ein fremdes Land und stellen fest, dass da ein anderes benutzt wird. Aber das ist auch alles Vorgeschichte. Das ist vorbei und vergessen.
Du meinst, weil die Produkte, die man einsetzt...
Genau, als praktisches Problem ist es vergessen. Weil die Algorithmen auch wirklich sehr einfach sind.
Ja, das heißt, es war irgendwann absehbar, dass man mit einem Computer die Telefonschnittstelle, ob es nun eine analoge Schnittstelle ist oder eben ISDN oder T1 oder was es da auch sonst noch alles gegeben hat und gibt. Also es gibt ja noch höher T2 und T3, also höher Density. Und ISDN selber kam ja in zwei Geschmacksrichtungen als Endkunden, Enduser-Lösung, wie wir das heute kennen, mit zwei Kanälen. Und die S2M-Lösung mit 30 Kanälen. Was natürlich für den Business-Einsatz sowohl für Telefonanlagen interessant war, aber eben auch für diejenigen, die jetzt massiv mit Computern auf dem Telefonnetz rumklimpern wollten.
Also ich schlage jetzt nochmal diesen Bogen zurück zu dieser Big-Mouth-Karte, die wie gesagt einen Kanal hatte. Das hatte unter anderem glaube ich einfach den Grund, dass so eine analoge Telefonschnittstelle relativ garstig ist elektrisch. Das Klingeln sind nämlich 60 Volt in etwa. Und wenn du viele, viele Leitungen terminieren willst, und du hast jeweils so einen kleinen 60 Volt, das ist einfach zu viel für so eine Platine, die innerhalb eines Gehäuses sitzt. Oder es ist jedenfalls ziemlich schwierig, da sagen wir mal so 60 kleine Terminatoren aufzubauen, die 60 analoge Leitungen verbinden. Das war auch einfach von der Kabellage her wirklich sehr, sehr unhandlich. Und deswegen kam diese Renaissance und dieses Aufblühen der Computer-Telefonie, zumindest diese IVA-Systeme, durch ISDN, weil da hatte man plötzlich nur noch zwei Dreite. Und die Signalisierung war völlig klar, und zwar digital, und zwar an Voltage-Levels, die wunderbar beherrschbar waren. Das war alles ganz prima zu machen im Vergleich zu so einer analogen Telefonleitung, die wirklich so gedacht ist, dass dein Ringer, also deine Glocke im Telefon, durch diese 60 Volt angeregt wird und dann wirklich mechanisch mit dem Klöppel das macht.
Darauf wollte ich übrigens hinaus mit der Signalisierung im analogen Bereich. Ja, aber wir haben schon beide vor der Sendung festgestellt, dass wir heute schon ein ganz gutes Programm abgeleistet haben. Und so zum späten Abend muss man sich auch erstmal sammeln. Aber dafür machen wir ja auch Podcasts, da kann man ja machen, was man will.
Aber nicht zu lange.
Nicht zu lange, das stimmt. Gut, genau, das ist nämlich das Ding. Also bei analog war einfach nicht wirklich händelbar. Man hat vielleicht genau eine einzige Leitung gehabt, dafür ging das vielleicht gerade noch so eben. Aber so Massensysteme...
Du hast vier auf eine Karte bekommen, das ging noch einigermaßen gut. Acht, das war schon ziemlich garstig, weil du hast ja auch nicht so viel Platz auf diesem PCB drauf. Das musst du ja alles unterbringen. Das waren dann schon Karten, die hatten dann Dota-Boards. Es war unglaublich unhandlich. Und mit ISDN war es dann möglich, das gut unterzubringen in einem Computer. Und dann ging das halt los.
Sprich, das Aufkommen von ISDN hat überhaupt erst, oder in den USA halt, den T1-Leitung, hat quasi überhaupt erst die Voraussetzung geschafft, dass man mit vielen Leitungen gleichzeitig interfacen konnte. Auf der anderen Seite bedurfte es aber auch, ja, bei der Computertechnik so einige Geschichten. Weil was heutzutage selbstverständlich ist, dass ein Computer diese Audio-Dateien problemlos aufzeichnen und abspielen kann. Das war Anfang der 90er Jahre. Wir reden von einem Zeitraum, wo 4,86er gerade anfingen, der heiße Scheiß zu sein.
Und da hatten die auch, glaube ich, noch unter 20 MHz.
Genau, da war da einfach nicht wirklich daran zu denken. Wenn überhaupt, dann vielleicht mal so ein Kanal, aber...
Die Bandbreiten auf dem Isar-Bus waren definitiv so, dass man sehr viel mehr als 30 am Anfang nicht machen konnte, weil man einfach die... der Streaming, also einfach die zwei Megabit, die man gleichzeitig streamen musste, das geht ja auch noch in beide Richtungen eventuell, da war man schon ziemlich am Ende der Bandbreite.
Vom Bus?
Vom Bus, des Isar-Buses.
Vom Prozessor aber gar nicht geredet. Diese Daten müssten ja dann auch durch einen Hauptspeicher geführt werden, da müsste irgendwas Sinnvolles mitgemacht werden. Also ein komplett softwareorientiertes System. Ich wäre darauf hinaus, dass zunächst einmal neue Hardware erforderlich war, um überhaupt mit dem Telefonnetz reden zu können, weil das alles in Software zu machen, wie man das heute einfach mal sich ausdenken könnte und wie das ja um zunehmendem Maße auch gemacht wird. Genau. Was für einen Begriff IVR fallen lassen?
Interactive Voice Response, ja. Alles mögliche, irgendwo, wo du anrufst und eine automatisierte Stimme dir was sagt. Also auch diese ganzen fürchterlichen Systeme drücken sie eins um, hast du da vielleicht mal ein Beispiel oder sowas, um das Fieses? Ich glaube, die Simpsons habe ich da auch mal drüber lustig gemacht. Drücken sie eins, um irgendwie mit dem Sales Department zu sprechen, drücken sie zwei, um dieses zu machen. Das sind auch IVR-Systeme.
Jeder kennt es. Jeder hat also genau aus.
Das war auch ein großer Markt. Also ich schreihe jetzt wieder ein bisschen ab, gehen wir wieder nach Amerika. In Amerika gab es ja kein ESDN und die haben auch keine Durchwahlen, weil die einen anderen Numbering klein haben. Da hat jede Telefonnummer dieselbe Länge und du kannst nicht wie in Deutschland sagen, irgendwie gib mir die 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 und dann die 0 ist meine Zentrale und dann die 1, 2 bin ich und die 1, 3 ist meine Frau und die 1, 4 ist meine Tochter und so weiter. Das geht alles nicht. Und dann hat man also Automated Attendance. Das war damals auch so ein ganz wichtiger Begriff. Dann kam man nämlich auf so ein IVA-System. Das hat einem gesagt, so jetzt können Sie irgendwie mit 1, 4...
Stimmt, den Aspekt habe ich noch gar nicht bedacht. Genau, man hat immer diese Extensions und wenn man da keinen Computer hat, dann hat man da eine Person.
Ganz genau.
Die brauchten einfach immer so ein, nicht ein Fräulein vom Amt, sondern Fräulein vom Empfang. Genau. Und die musste dann erst mal zu den Nebenstellen durchstellen.
Manuell.
Ganz genau.
Wäre das in Deutschland eigentlich nie so das Ding war, war mit ESDN das Problem schon relativ lange gelöst.
Das gab es auch schon auf Analog. Das hieß, oh, das war vor meiner Zeit, IKZ oder so, keine Ahnung. Aber ja, das Problem hat sich so in Deutschland nicht gestellt. Also die Auto Attendance hat es nicht gegeben.
Ach so, da wurde vor der Telefonanlage Nachwahl geliefert. Das heißt, das war mit Tonwahl, war das dann sozusagen. Mit Touchtonen wurde das dann gemacht, oder?
Die sind, glaube ich, das ist Spekulation. Ich glaube, die Schnittstelle ist noch älter und das ging wirklich teilweise auch über den Road Redial. Dass das dann weitergeleitet wurde. Krass.
IKZ hast du gesagt? Ich bin die Kanzlerin. Na, IKZ ist ja das Impulskennzeichen.
Ja, vielleicht erzähle ich noch Quatsch.
Das Grat. Wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall. Daraus entstand halt ein erster Markt in den USA. Und dann ging es halt los mit, wie du schon gesagt hast, Auskunftssystemen.
Genau.
Dann hat man Kreditkarten, Buchungsschnickes, Flugbuchungs-tralala, so eine Sachen. Da gab es auch diesen schönen Namen Audiotex. Gibt es den eigentlich noch?
Den Namen gibt es. Ich weiß nicht, da musst du Wikipedia fragen. Da habe ich nie verstanden, was das wirklich sein soll.
Es klingt so ein bisschen wie so eine...
Das muss von Tele-Text gekommen sein. Dass man versucht, ein ähnliches Informationsangebot, wie damals unter BTX verfügbar war, übers Telefon zur Verfügung zu stellen. Aber das ist alles Spekulation. Ich habe keinen blassen Schimmer.
Ja, also diese ganze Idee von Diensten über das Telefonnetz, die man eigentlich nur mit Computern realisieren kann, weil man sonst Horden von Bearbeitern hätte, wie man es damals hatte bei der Auskunft. Aber das skaliert nicht, wie man so schön sagt. Audio-Text war damals die Klammer für alles, was in irgendeiner Form mit CTI zu tun hat. Audio-Text war quasi das Dienstewesen. Und IVR war die konkreten Anwendungen. Und CTI ist sozusagen die Technologie, die damit zu tun hat.
Wobei ich das jetzt nochmal auftrennen wollte. Diese IVR-Audio-Text sind einfach Applikationen, die wirklich im Dialog mit dem Anrufer stehen, über DTMF-Töne gesteuert werden oder dann später mit automatischer Spracherkennung, mit ASR, die eventuell auch später dann eine Textsynthese hatten. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch die Computer-Telefonie-Integration in dem Sinne, dass ich meine Nebenstellenanlage in einer großen Firma integriere mit meinem Computernetz. Oder dass ich auch sehen kann, irgendwie meine Sekretärin ist besetzt. Oder dieser Anrufer, der da reinkommt, der ist in Wirklichkeit nicht nur auf dem Bildschirm irgendwie Herr Müller, sondern auch Herr Müller hat letztes Mal einen gerufen und sich beschwert über XYZ oder Wiedervorlage, keine Ahnung. Also die ganze Integration des rationellen Telefonierens in den Arbeitsablauf des Büromenschen. Das ist so eine andere Stoßrichtung und das hat auch ganz andere...
Das ist aber eher Telefonanlagenintegration, würde ich das jetzt mal nennen.
Das heißt aber auch CTI. Das können wir aber einfach auslassen.
Genau, wir müssen es nicht auslassen, aber vielleicht konzentrieren wir uns erst mal auf diesen rein... Womit es ja im Prinzip technisch auch anfing. Ich habe jetzt meinen Computer und ich will jetzt direkt mit dem Telefonnetz reden. Analoge Welt ist so weit vorbei, dass man eben auf ISDN bzw. T1 oder was auch immer in den USA derzeit noch zum Einsatz kommt, setzen kann. Was war denn dann sozusagen das Erste nach der BigMouse? Also was war denn sozusagen das erste Board oder das erste System, was mir als Programmierer die Möglichkeit gegeben hat, mit dem Telefonnetz zu reden und eben auch diese Sprache abzuspielen oder aufzunehmen, je nachdem, was ich brauchte, ohne jetzt meinen Prozessor zum Einsatz bringen zu müssen?
Ich glaube, so ordentlich war die Geschichte damals nicht. So ordentlich ist die Geschichte nicht. Es gab dann, wie gesagt, diese Automated Attendance.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es ordentlich ist.
Ich habe nur gefragt, was das ist. Das nächste, das nächste impliziert, dass es irgendwie einigermaßen so eine Reihenfolge gab. Ich glaube, das gab es gar nicht.
Oder was ist die nächste professionelle Kategorie, die jetzt erwähnenswert ist?
Die nächste interessante Kategorie sind dann, glaube ich, Systeme, die aus mehr als einer Karte bestehen. Das heißt, ich habe eine Line-Interface-Karte, wie das dann üblicherweise hieß, die zum Beispiel in der Lage ist, 30 Kanäle ISDN, also ein S2M oder ein PMXer zu terminieren. Und dann habe ich zum Beispiel eine Karte, die in der Lage ist, die Sprache abzuspielen und DTMFs zu erkennen. Und die sitzen jetzt im selben Computerschassi und müssen aber isochrone Daten miteinander austauschen.
Isochrone Daten?
Also zeitgetaktete Daten.
Sprich so, wie das Sprachencoding eben ist. Das kommt einfach gnadenlos rein. Das ist nicht in Pakete eingepackt, wie bei TCPIP, sondern das kommt einfach.
Genau, das ist ein gnadenlos, das ist ein Takt. Das ist ein wirklich ordentlich geheizter Kristall, der irgendwo in der Nähe von Darmstadt in einem unterirdischen Bunker steht, der das deutsche ISDN mit dem Takt versorgt. Da kommt die steigende Flanke rein und fünf Mikrosekunden später ist dein Sample gültig.
Echt, der Telefonen-Kristall liegt in Darmstadt?
Hat mal jemand behauptet. Auch nicht in Darmstadt, sondern bestimmt unterhalb Darmstads. Wenn ich ein Terrorist wäre, würde ich das Ding in die Luft sprengen. Aber es gibt Backups, das weiß ich auch. Das ist jedenfalls getaktet. Die Computerbosse sind asynchron. Die Sprachdaten sind isochron. Sie kommen getaktet immer schön rein. Und die sind dann getaktet und auch immer schön weitergeleitet worden zwischen den Boards. Und da hat man sich verschiedene Busstandards überlegt, mit denen man Karten dann auch eventuell, das ist dann schon die nächste Stufe, mehrere Hersteller miteinander verbinden konnte. Fingen sie sicherlich damit an, dass ein Hersteller festgestellt hat, wir kriegen 30 DTMF-Decoder gar nicht mehr auf die Trankkarte drauf. Und wir brauchen einen Dota-Board für dieses Feature. Und dann muss man das trennen und dann trennt man einfach, hat man diesen Bus da definiert.
Was war denn dieser erste Bus? Du redest jetzt von diesen Dialogic-Dingern?
Das war zum Beispiel, das ist einer der Beispiele, der PEP.
PEP-Standard. Oder Standard war es wahrscheinlich nicht, sondern es war eine Produktreihe von Dialogic.
Genau, ich weiß es auch gar nicht.
Die ja noch ein relativ großer Zampano sind in dem Geschäft.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, in welchem Zustand die sind.
Was wollte der?
Der konnte, glaube ich, 32 Timeslots. Also wirklich einen Primär-Multiplexer plus die zwei D-Kanäle, die konnte der.
Zwei D-Kanäle?
Er hat nur einen D-Kanäle, das andere ist Synchronisation. Aber der konnte, glaube ich, 32 Timeslots konnte der. Mehr konnte der nicht. Also es ist schon sehr, sehr limitiert.
Okay, das heißt, nur, wenn man jetzt mal dieses Setup versteht. Also man hat seinen Computer, wie man ihn kennt, so. Oder wie man ihn damals kannte zumindest. Und dann hat man so ein ISDN-Loch da in der Wand. So, da kommt dann so ein S2M-Interface, wie man so schön sagt. Oder auch der PMXer, der Primär-Multiplexer-Anschluss. Für dieses Wort gehören sie eigentlich auch, fand ich das. Aber egal, so ein PMXer, so sagt man es, liefert halt 30 Basis-Kanäle, also 30 Sprachkanäle an. Plus eben die Signalisierung, der D-Kanal. So, und den steckt man jetzt direkt in... Ach so, in seinem PC hat man so eine Karte.
Genau.
Das ist das Trunk-Interface. Trunk für der Anschluss an das Netz. So, da ist die passende Buchse, wo man sein S2M direkt anschließen kann. Und dann schlägt er dort auf. Und dann hat man aber noch weitere Karten in demselben Computer, alle nebeneinander stehen. Also man hatte damals Isa, Bus, wie das eben so war. Und dann steckte so die Trunk-Karte. Und was steckte dann daneben?
Die Sprachverarbeitungskarte oder die Conferencing-Karte oder die Spracherkennungskarte oder die Text-Synthese-Karte.
Gab es die denn alle schon für Pepp?
Für Pepp weiß ich nicht. Oh, für Pepp gab es mit Sicherheit Fax-Karten.
Oh ja, für Fax ist das natürlich auch.
Da kam das wahrscheinlich sogar her.
Okay, aber der einfachste Fall ist eigentlich, du hast eine Trankkarte. Das heißt, eine Karte, die kann ISDN, aber auch nicht sehr viel mehr. Das heißt, die Karte war im Wesentlichen mit Logik beschäftigt, um überhaupt erst mal mit ISDN klarzukommen. Und sehr viel mehr passt es auch nicht drauf oder wollte keiner bezahlen. Und dann ist die nächste Karte daneben, macht das Voice-Processing.
Genau, DTMF-Erkennung und dann das Abspielen von Audiodaten in Blockgrößen, die besser zum ISA-Bus passen.
Und wie sind die beiden Karten miteinander verbunden?
Mit dem PEP-Bus zum Beispiel, wenn wir dieses Beispiel herausgreifen. Das ist dieser ISO-Krone-Bus. Das ist ein, ich glaube, zehnpoliges Flat-Ribbon-Kabel. So ähnlich wie das, ich glaube, man konnte Floppy-Kabel benutzen. Aber das war sogar noch ein bisschen schmaler als ein Floppy-Kabel. Also so ein dünnes Flat-Bahn-Kabel.
Das heißt, die Karten hatten nach oben einen Stecker.
Genau.
So ein Flat-Bahn-Kabel-Stecker.
Und da hat man die drauf gestattet.
Und dann macht man so ein Plum-Plum-Plum-Plum-Plum von Karte neben Karte. Alle hatten den Stecker an derselben Position. Und dann ging das Kabel einfach oben vollständig separat von dem Computer-Bus.
Da war ein Glück, dass alle an derselben Position.
Bei so einem Flachbandkabel wäre das schon ganz angemessen.
Das gab es alles. Doch, doch, einige waren dann noch ein Standard. Da musste man dann irgendwie Knoten in das Flachbandkabel machen. Das war ganz schrecklich. Oh weia. Ja, war fürchtebar.
So, das heißt, dieser Pepbus konnte einfach 30 Kanäle. Und der nächste Schritt war sozusagen die Antwort der anderen Hersteller, die auch mitspielen wollten.
Genau, NMS hat dann gekontert mit dem MVIP, Multivender, oh Gott, das werden keine Ahnung, Integration Platform, Protocol, Protocol, genau. Genau, und der konnte schon deutlich mehr.
NMS ist auch eine amerikanische Firma.
Genau. Die haben das auch dann gleich in ein Standardsgremium im Prinzip gegründet oder befördert, dass eben der PEP war nur die Logic und andere Leute durften sozusagen auch was machen, aber konnten da nichts zu sagen. Und NMS hat das dann als Standard aufgezogen und da richtig ein Forum gegründet, wo man sich unterhalten hat vor über die technischen Spezifikationen des Buses und die konnten da dann mitreden und der hatte glaube ich 1024 Timeslots. Also da konnte man schon deutlich mehr machen.
Also man konnte nicht nur 1 PMXer sein, sondern theoretisch 16 oder 32.
Genau, diese 1024 waren aber glaube ich auch, das ist ja auch egal. Also eine deutliche Steigerung der Kapazität. Und der hatte so eine maximale Länge von ich glaube einem halben Meter oder 30 Zentimeter. Also allzu weit ausdehnen konnte man den nicht. Und dafür gab es dann wirklich Karten, die Sprachsynthese gemacht haben. Da gab es Spracherkennerkarten, da gab es Faxkarten, da gab es Conferencekarten, die nur Konferenzen gerechnet haben. Und es gab Karten, die Pulscode-Erkennung gemacht haben. Also man konnte dann eine Zeit lang, waren wirklich einzelne Funktionsblöcke auf einzelne spezialisierte Karten verteilt, die teilweise von allen, alle von unterschiedlichen Herstellern kamen. Und das hat eine Zeit lang relativ gut funktioniert, bis dann die Geschichte das wieder eingeholt hat. Es ging dann noch ein Stückchen weiter. Dialogic hat auf MWRP mit dem SCSA geantwortet. Die haben eine Zeit lang neben sich her existiert, parallel.
Was ist SCSA?
Das war ursprünglich noch etwas größer angelegt. Das war die Single Computing Systems Architecture und hat von der AP, also wirklich der C-Programmiersprachenschnittstelle, wie spiele ich einen Pfeil mit meinen Karten ab, bis zu wie erkenne ich einen DTMF, wie mache ich einen ausgehenden Anruf, wie nehme ich einen eingehenden Anruf entgegen und so weiter. Alles spezifiziert bis runter auf diesen Boss. Das Treiberinterface hat man immer in Ruhe gelassen, das wurde nicht spezifiziert, aber das Interface zur Applikation wurde spezifiziert und das physikalische Interface zwischen den verschiedenen Karten wurde auch spezifiziert. Das Ganze war auch noch erweiterbar, dass man also ASR zum Beispiel da hätte einhängen können.
Spracherkennung.
Spracherkennung, genau.
Wo du gerade Treiber erwähnst, was wir nicht so richtig erwähnt haben, ist, welche Betriebssysteme damals eigentlich zum Einsatz kamen.
Das waren ja auch fürchterliche Zeiten. Das war vor Windows NT. Fingen wir es an. OS 2. Was gab es? Ein Unix. Go Unix gab es auch. Das war ganz fürchterlich. Unix-Ware hatte er auch noch. Da gab es, glaube ich, auch für die ATs gab es auch ein Unix-Ware.
Also das Novell-Unix?
Das Novell-Unix, genau. Da gab es so ein paar ganz wenige Unix eigentlich, obwohl die auf den Prozessoren gut hätten laufen können. Das war aber vor Linux. Und die professionellen Unix waren sehr teuer und sehr schlecht. Man muss auch sagen, sehr schlecht. Ich habe da fürchterliche Erinnerungen. Da funktionierte wirklich die Hälfte nicht.
Der OS2 hatte damals eigentlich so seine beste Zeit.
Kurzfristig.
Also mit der Version 2.0. Weil es doch recht performant war, multithreaded war. Also überhaupt so die ganze Nebenläufigkeit von daher ganz gut unterstützt hat, was so bei Unix überhaupt nicht präsent war.
Ja, überhaupt den 386er einfach wirklich ausgenutzt hat. Oder die Kraft, die die Power des Prozessors. Mit einem 386er kannst du ein Multitasking-Betriebssystem machen. Also ohne größere Verrenkung. Und diese Fähigkeiten des Prozessors, dem der Applikation zur Verfügung zu stellen, das war US-2 so eine der frühen bezahlbaren Alternativen, wurden dann aber auch schon kurze Zeit später wieder von Windows NT abgelöst. Das kam nicht so fürchterlich wie später. Und war einfach deutlich schicker, sah hübscher aus. Das fanden die Leute. Und hatte dieselben Features.
Das heißt, Windows NT war dann in zunehmendem Maße auch die CTI-Plattform?
Unbedingt. Da war dann Windows NT. Ich glaube, mit den Unixen haben immer welche rumgespielt und es auch hingekriegt. Das ging schon. Aber es war noch relativ murkelig. Also in der CTI sieht man jetzt Unix eigentlich erst seit Linux richtig am Start, würde ich behaupten. Und jetzt ist es natürlich extrem weit verbreitet. Ist klar.
Ja, wie ging denn das weiter mit dieser SCSA-Geschichte? War das jetzt nur so ein Schuss gegen diesen MVIP, um zu sagen, wir sind jetzt auch mal Multi-Evendor und wir machen das jetzt auch? Und dann ist das so eine Vaporware, die nur dazu da ist, den anderen erst mal so eine Angst einzujagen, dass sie nicht mehr weiterentwickeln und dann kommt nichts?
Das war unbedingt eine Vaporware, die ist dann übergegangen. Man hat sich dann geeinigt, dass man eben doch zusammenarbeiten müsste. Ich glaube, der Euphemismus war dann, dass der Markt wächst durch diese Konvergenz. So wurde das den Sales-Leuten schmackhaft gemacht. Und da gab es dann die ECTF, Enterprise Computer Telephony Forum. Da haben sich dann NMS und Dialogic zusammengetan und haben die nächste Version des Busstandards spezifiziert. Das ist der HN100 und dann der HN110, der auf Compact-PCI lief. Und da wurde dann auch ein relativ ernsthafter Versuch unternommen, mal diese ganzen Schnittstellen für Sprachverarbeitung zu standardisieren. Das ist dann aber auch...
Das war ja ein totaler Wildwuchs, nicht? Also jeder Hersteller hat zusammen...
Es ist immer noch ein totaler Wildwuchs. Also eigentlich ist es zum Erbarmen. Es ist immer noch ein ganz fürchterlicher Wildwuchs. Es gibt, glaube ich, immer noch mehr Voice-Ups, als ich Finger an meiner Hand habe. Und ernstzunehmend, private gibt es tausende wahrscheinlich. Also dieser Wildwuchs ist auch nie wirklich weggegangen. Weil die Frameworks, die man da spezifiziert hat, dann relativ heavyweight waren und dass die Hersteller dann einfach nicht... Das hätte wirklich Engineering-Men-Years gekostet, um das sauber zu unterstützen. Und das hat einfach dann keiner gemacht. Das ist dann spezifiziert worden. Da sind irgendwie ein paar ältere Ingenieure für ein paar Jahre abgeschoben worden. Gebt mal eure Standards schreiben. Aber in der Zwischenzeit gab es schon irgendwie drei Boardversionen weiter. Da war man drei Boardversionen weiter und man hatte keine Zeit, das irgendwie an den Standard anzupassen oder das irgendwie zusammen zu halten. Dann hat man es einfach gelassen.
Aber ist denn jetzt dieses H100, also H100 ist die Hardware-Plattform?
Das ist der Bus-Standard.
Das spezifiziert, wie die Karten untereinander reden.
Genau.
Und das ist nach wie vor diese Flachbandkabel-Geschichte.
Das ist H100 ist Flachbandkabel und H110 hat sich einen Jumper registriert auf dem PicMik 2, irgendwas Standard. Also Compact PCI ist so eine Midplane-Chassis-Architektur.
Was meinst du damit mit Midplane?
Midplane, das heißt, dass du eine Karte hast, die du von vorne rein schiebst. Dann hat die so ein paar Jumper. Das sind, weißte, kannst du dich an den Newbus erinnern?
Dem vom alten Macintosh?
Genau, der hatte doch so relativ aufwändige Konnekturen. Da wo man die Karte draufsteckt. Genau, und so ein Compact PCI-Chassis ist ein Rechner. Der hat in der Mitte seinen Bus. Und du schiebst wirklich von vorne die Karte rein. Die hat dann so drei reige Konnekturen, auch mehrere übereinander.
Reden wir jetzt von 19 Zoll Equipment?
Wir reden jetzt von 19 Zoll Equipment, genau. Du schiebst die Karte da rein, dann wird zuallererst die Stromversorgung verbunden, dann bootet die Karte, und dann ist es auch relativ pleatsch so gemacht, dass du die elektrisch ohne allzu fürchterliche Störungen im laufenden Betrieb reinstecken kannst. Und dann hast du einen Jumper frei, der ist nach hinten durch verdrahtet. Und da kannst du dann dein Rear-Transition-Modul noch draufschieben. Und da sind dann zum Beispiel deine E1-Interfaces drauf. Da sind dann deine Ethernet, Rear-Transition-Modul.
Das ist jetzt ein Begriff von Compact PCI?
Ja, das ist diese ganze größere 19 Zoll-Chassis-Technik. Du willst ja vorne nicht deinen Kabelsalat raushaben. Das sieht ja unordentlich aus. Deswegen hast du die Rear-Transition-Module hinten. Und kannst damit deinen Kabelsalat hinten haben. Und hast vorne dann nur noch irgendwelche DIP-Switches oder Anzeigen und LEDs und solche Sachen.
Das heißt, ich schiebe trotzdem von vorne die Karte rein, was auch immer, so ein Trunk-Interface.
Genau.
Und dann stecke ich aber noch was von hinten da drauf.
Genau, das heißt, es kommt zum Beispiel dein E1-Frame oder irgendwas, was relativ selten kaputt geht, wo kein CPU drauf ist, oder wo einfach nur eine einfache elektrische Umsetzung gemacht wird, das kommt von hinten drauf. Und das, was kaputt gehen kann, das kommt von vorne drauf. Und dann kannst du das eventuell auch, wenn das redundant ausgeführt ist, im laufenden Betrieb eines vorne rausziehen. Und dann kannst du Neues reinstecken. Und wenn dann alles gut ist, dann ist danach alles fast wieder wie vorher.
Und da hatte sich in diesem …Ist das jetzt sozusagen noch …Das gibt es. Das gibt es noch und das ist jetzt auch das, was zum Einsatz kommt.
Das kommt auch zum Einsatz. Aber auch bei weitem nicht überall, weil das relativ teuer ist.
Der H100-Kram ist teuer?
Nein, nein.
Und das H110?
Diese PicMake-216-Chassis, diese PCI-Express …Nicht PCI-Express, Compact PCI-Chassis kosten einfach mindestens 5000 Dollar. Damit hast du bloß einen Chassis.
Okay, ich wollte jetzt nur mal Griffe klären. Also H100 ist die Hardware-Definition …Flachbandkabel, genau. Mit Flachbandkabel für PCI-Karten.
Und vor allem die Signal-Definition. Das ist eigentlich das Wichtige.
Und H110?
Mapped einfach …Ist das selbe? Flachbandkabel, das linke auf Pin 17, das zweite von links auf Pin 18 und so weiter und so fort. Eines Jumpers auf Compact PCI. Das ist ansonsten elektrisch dasselbe.
Und das ist aber jetzt sozusagen auch noch im CTI-Geschäft die verbreitete Spezifikation. Also wenn man heute was kauft, dann kauft man nach wie vor PCI-Karten und dann kauft man nach wie vor H100-Karten.
Nein, heutzutage kaufst du das glaube ich nicht mehr außer du hast irgendwie gute Gründe es zu tun. Das sind ja alles Sachen, die haben eine Produktlaufzeit, die ist nicht fürchterlich lang, aber sagen wir mal schon mal 5 Jahre. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt irgendwas planen würde, was größeres, dann würde ich schon sehr ernsthaft über nachdenken, ob ich Advanced TCA mache, ob ich Micro TCA mache. Wahrscheinlich wäre ich dann versucht, Micro TCA zu machen und dann würde ich...
Okay, jetzt springst du aber nach vorne. Du fragst. Meine Frage war, ist jetzt sozusagen H100 das, was es bis heute geschafft hat oder ist das jetzt auch nur ein Schritt in der Geschichte? Also ist H100 mittlerweile schon wieder von irgendetwas abgelöst worden oder hat sich im Prinzip diese SCSA-Architektur gehalten?
Nein, diese Isochrono-Busarchitektur ist im Moment am Aussterben. Das ist das, worauf ich hinaus will. Und zwar kommt das gar nicht daher, das kommt aus zwei Richtungen. Die erste Richtung ist selbst H100 und H110 haben nur 4096 unidirektionale Timeslots. Das heißt, ich kriege auch nur 2048 vollständige 1 zu 1 Verbindungen Duplex hin. Das ist so fürchterlich viel bei heutigen Dichten nicht mehr. Das reicht vorne und hinten nicht. Das ist der eine Punkt.
Kann man damit nicht theoretisch 2000 Telefonanrufe irgendwie dealen?
Ja, aber das ist doch nichts. 2000 Telefonanrufe, was ist denn das? Lass mich mal kurz ausrechnen.
Gleichzeitig?
Ach, das ist doch gar nichts. Bei heutigen Dichten, du kriegst auf einem... Ein heutiger PC mit Asterisk und SIP rechnet dir 350 Leitungen gleichzeitig. Der ist noch nicht mehr besonders groß. Da hat dann irgendwie der Prozessor schon irgendwie vielleicht mehr als einen Kern und 2,43 Gigahertz. Aber da kriegst du 350 Kanäle locker mitgerechnet. Und die Integrationsdichte bei den Carriers ist noch viel, viel höher. Da dreht es sich dann wirklich um Standfläche, da dreht es sich um Stromverbrauch.
Das heißt, diese Technik ist auch in Telefonvermittlungsstellen mittlerweile im Einsatz? Weil, ich meine, so wie wir es jetzt dargestellt haben, reden wir ja sozusagen von End-User-Technologie. Zwar nicht Konsumer, sondern halt Telefondienste, Anbieter irgendwie. Ich mache meine Pornoleien, ich mache irgendwie mein Auskunftssystem und so weiter. Dann stelle ich mir da zwei Rexeln, baller mir da ein paar PCs rein, da kommen diese Karten rein. Dann wird da ein bisschen Fotosoftware drüber gelaufen. Dann kommt die PMX rein und fertig ist die Laube.
Ich habe echt keine Ahnung. Also vielen Dank, dass du die Pornoleien erwähnst. Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich meinte Schmurdelkinder. Genau, da muss man auch nochmal kurz drauf zurückkommen. Ja, das ist, glaube ich, ein relativ wichtiger Anwendungsbereich. Der wird wirklich genau so betrieben. Aber diese Leute machen natürlich nicht Compact PCI, sondern die kaufen sich die billigsten Karten, die sie bekommen. Da braucht es ja auch keine Interaktivität. Da brauchst du ja auch nicht Anrufer miteinander verschalten zu können. Du spielst einfach das Gestöhne ab. Da kannst du im Prinzip auch 2000 Anrufbeantworter nebeneinander stellen, nur dass sich das nicht rechnet. Ja, das gibt es. Aber es gibt natürlich, ich glaube mal, die größten CTI-Anwendungen, die größten IVA-Anwendungen stehen wahrscheinlich sehr wohl bei den Carriers. Das sind ganz einfach die netzwerkbasierten Anrufbeantworter.
Richtig, das ist ja eine Dienstleistung, die mittlerweile von den Telefonnetz-Provalern selber übernommen wird.
Genau, die Zeit, dass man sich seinen eigenen Anrufbeantworter gekauft hat, ist vorbei, weil du kriegst sowieso deine T-Net-Box, ob du sie haben willst oder nicht, und musst sie eigentlich erst ausschalten, sodass da wirklich solche Anlagen stehen. Die großen Auskünfte werden, glaube ich, im Wesentlichen auch immer noch von den Careern selber betrieben.
Okay, ja klar, wenn man so auf Netzebene denkt, dann ist natürlich 2048 auf einmal nicht so viel, wenn man Millionen Kunden hat. Und ja, aber was wird denn dann dort eingesetzt, wenn nicht mehr H100-Kram?
ITDM, würde ich behaupten. Das würde ich jedenfalls planen. Was? ITDM ist ein ganz wichtiges Wort, das haben wir noch nicht erwähnt. Ah, jetzt habe ich es vergessen.
Meinst du Time Division?
Time Domain, Time Division Multiplexing. Das ist das, was du machst, wenn du mehrere Sprachkanäle gleichzeitig über ein paar Draht übermitteln willst. Dann macht man Time Division Multiplexing. Du teilst einfach einen Zeitschlitz. Wir wollen jetzt bei ISDN 32 Timeslots übertragen. 30 davon sind Sprache, einer ist der D-Kanal, der zweite ist für die Synchronisierung. Du teilst es also in 32 Zeitschlitze auf dieses Fenster und überträgst dann jeweils davon ein Bit oder ein Byte. Das ist Time Division Multiplexing.
Also quasi die zur Verfügung stehende Bandbreite in Zeitschlitze aufteilt. Dann habe ich N-Kanäle, dann wird das geäntelt und dann wird entsprechend da ein Häppchen reingetan. Man wählt seine Häppchengröße nach irgendwelchen Maßgaben. Ganz genau. Was auch immer rüberkommen soll.
Genau. Und das macht man jetzt heutzutage über Ethernet. Und das kommt daher, dass die Chassis-Hersteller einfach damit angefangen haben, zwei Gigabit physikalische Netze in die Backplane einzubauen. Von so Advanced TCA oder Micro TCA.
Wir haben jetzt gerade ein bisschen Begriffesstau. Also TCA hast du vorhin schon erwähnt, aber ich weiß immer noch nicht, was das ist.
Das sind diese fürchterlichen Begriffe. Diese TLA's einfach.
Ja klar, aber was bezeichnet das jetzt? Hardware, Software, Architektur?
Das ist Hardware, das ist Chassis. Das sind Chassis-Spezifikationen. Mein Chassis ist 19 Zoll breit, das ist schon klar. Und dann wie groß ist eine Karte? Wie ist die Karte physikalisch da drin? Wie ist der Konnektor nach hinten? Das ist alles Chassis-Technologie.
Okay, das hat aber auch das H100 quasi definiert?
Nein, das H110, ja. Das reicht da mit rein. Wir dürfen das nicht vermischen. Es gibt die elektrische Spezifikation, und das würde ich sagen, ist der Kern von H100, der einfach sagt, wir haben diesen getakteten Bus, und ab der steigenden Flanke ist dann dieses Sample gültig. Und dann haben wir den physikalischen Transport, der eben ein Flachbandkabel sein kann oder der ein Stück auf der Backplane eines größeren Chassis sein kann. Und das ist dann der Unterschied zwischen 110 und H100. Und dann heutzutage haben wir eben als physikalischen Transport Ethernet, und da wird dann TDM über auf Ethernet-Frames gemacht.
Das heißt, da stecken aber nach wie vor mehrere Karten im selben Computer, und die sind mit Ethernet verbunden?
Genau, ganz genau.
Und die haben dann so CAD5-Stecker noch mal oben drauf?
Nein, das ist in der Backplane. Das ist das gigabit Ethernet, und zwar das redundante gigabit Ethernet, ist auf der Backplane. Du hast deine Karten, die hast du rausgezogen. Die sind riesig groß.
Also mit Backplane meinst du quasi das Mainboard des Computers?
Nein, es gibt kein Mainboard mehr. Bei diesen Systemen, okay, oh Gott, ich hätte viel früher anfangen müssen. Diese Systeme, die man dort bei den Carriern einsetzt, das sind Chassis, die bestehen aus einem Bus, der wirklich hinten drin steckt oder in der Mitte drin steckt und dann ganz vielen Einschubkarten, von denen ist typischerweise einer der Host, der alles kontrolliert und dann habe ich irgendwie eine Karte, die macht 32 Primär-Multiplexer.
Aber dieser Bus ist sozusagen schon dieser H100-Bus.
Dieser Bus ist die Backplane und da läuft dann, da lief früher PCI wirklich auf diesem Bus plus H100, also Compact PCI sozusagen in dieser Form ist, du hast als Bus-System den PCI-Bus, der den ESA-Bus abgelöst hat, wir diskutieren Bus-System, was sollten wir da nicht machen?
Doch?
Okay. Du hattest den, da läuft wirklich der PCI-Bus drauf, elektrisch, also oder logisch und zusätzlich noch da ein Hundert-Bus und die neueren Systeme, wie eben Advanced TCA oder diese ganzen TCA, Telecoms, keine Ahnung, ich muss mal nachgucken, guck du mal nach. Die sagen, es gibt gar keinen PCI-Bus mehr, sondern es gibt nur noch Ethernet. Die Kommunikation zwischen zwei Nodes innerhalb meines Chassis findet über Ethernet und wahrscheinlich dann auch noch über IP statt.
Das heißt, wir reden von dedizierten Computereinheiten, also Gehäusen, die einfach exakt genau für diesen Anwendungszweck schon gebaut sind?
Ja, und für das meditäre und für medizinische Anwendungen, wenn du irgendwelche...
Na gut, ich meine, da muss man ja auch erst mal so weit kommen, dass so ein Hardware-Business groß genug wird, dass es sich lohnt, dafür eben dedizierte Systeme zu bauen, wenn man vorher mit Flachbandkabeln in einem normalen PC gearbeitet hat. Das war jetzt auch so der Sprung, den ich nicht so ganz gemacht habe. Ja, ich weiß nicht. Also die Wikipedia, muss ich sagen, ist ja normalerweise bei mir ein beliebtes Ziel, wenn es um Links geht, zu Begriffen, die bei Chaosradio Express zum Einsatz kommen. Aber, da sind wir wahrscheinlich wieder in dieser Schmuddelecke, es steht da fast nichts zu drinnen. Also fast keiner dieser Begriffe, die wir irgendwie, also man, wahrscheinlich denken jetzt schon alle, die ein bisschen nachgeschlagen haben, so, das steht nicht in der Wikipedia, das kann es nicht geben. Ja, wahrscheinlich wird dieser Podcast gerade als der Fake-Podcast, der erste April-Podcast von Chaosradio Express geoutet, so. Ja, da reden sie eine, anderthalb Stunden über ein Thema, was es überhaupt nicht gibt.
Ja, da gibt es, da gibt es aber sehr aus, da gibt es, da gibt es, da gibt es sehr ernst aussehende Männer, die sehr schlecht sitzen, Anzüge tragen und die den ganzen Tag in der Welt rumfahren und über sowas nachdenken und reden und versuchen, sowas zu verkaufen. Das gibt es, auch wenn es in der Wikipedia nicht vorkommt. Ich schick dir mal den Link. Das ist auch eine Pick-Mick-Spezifikation. Next-Generation Telecommunications Equipment, ach frag mich nicht, ich bin heute schwach drauf.
Ja, aber was bezeichnet denn Pick-Mick?
Pick-MG, das ist ursprünglich, glaube ich, die Gruppe, die den PCI-Bus spezifiziert hat.
Ah, PCI-Industrie.
Genau, Pick-Micks, Original Mission was to extend the PCI-Standard from the PCI Special Interest Group, blablabla, genau. Die haben ein relativ niedriges Profil, haben aber, wie gesagt, da relativ viel zu sagen, weil die ganzen Hardware-Hersteller und vor allem auch die ganzen neuen Chinesen da sich einfach sklavisch nach Pick-Mick 2.16 oder 3.0 implementieren und das ist dann einfach in Stein gegossen und das ist das Gesetz.
Also wenn ich jetzt heute ein System aufsetze, also angenommen ich bin jetzt ein Netzprovider, ich baue irgendwo in einem fernen Land ein neues GSM-Netzwerk auf und da müssen natürlich auch die Anrufbeantworter dazu, dann würde ich mir irgendwo so ein fettes Warehouse, Data Warehouse hinstellen und da hätte ich dann diese dedizierten Chassis, die dann gleich irgendwie die richtigen Busse auf der Backplane haben, dass ich nur noch so meine Module da draufballer und diese PCM-Intern zwischen den Modulen hin und herleitet Technologie, die es im Prinzip immer noch gibt, so wie es Anfang der 90er Jahre entstanden ist, ist Ethernet.
Mittlerweile. Genau.
Und man spricht da, ja, man benutzt aber einfach die rohen Ethernet-Pakete, kein IP, kein Schnickes und Gedöns, sondern man nimmt halt einfach diesen Bus, weil dieser Bus ist eh schon da, da muss man irgendwie das ganze Silikon nicht für neu finden und das steigert sich auch am laufenden Meter und das gibt es mittlerweile auch schon in 10 Gigabit und gebildet.
Und du hast einfach relativ viel weniger Probleme, wenn du deinen ITDM kannst, wenn du es notwendig hast, wahrscheinlich noch mit VHDL in Hardware gießen und in den IP-Stack nicht mehr. Also das dreht sich wirklich darum, dass du möglichst wenig zwischen dir und deinem Prozessor hast.
Und vor allem, man braucht nicht mehr so viele Kabel, weil vorher diese fetten Flaffbandkabel, das war ja irgendwie das eine, aber wenn man jetzt einfach Ethernet nehmen kann, guckt man halt mit acht Kabeln aus und fertig ist.
Genau, also du brauchst ja auch glaube ich nur vier. Bei Gigabit auch?
Da braucht man langsam aber alle acht.
Das kann sein.
Okay. Und was wird denn dann darüber gesprochen? Also wenn jetzt das Ganze auf Ethernet geht, kommt denn diese SCSA-Architektur überhaupt noch zum Einsatz?
Nein.
Sondern?
Selbstgebasteltes. Also wie gesagt, es gibt das, was wirklich unbedingt spezifiziert werden muss, ist, wie transportiere ich Echtzeit-Sprachdaten von einer Karte auf die andere? Und das ist momentan, sehe ich das ITDM, da multiplext man, wirklich Time Division multiplexing, ein Ethernet-Frame hat 1500 Bytes, ich weiß nicht, ob die mit Jumbo-Frames arbeiten oder nicht, da packe ich irgendwie erst ein Byte von Time Slot 0 rein, dann eins von eins und so weiter und so fort. Da packe ich maximal viele Daten, versuche mein Ethernet-Frame voll zu bekommen, multiplexed, damit ich möglichst wenig Latenz habe auf dem Bus. Das ist das, was spezifiziert werden muss, das ist spezifiziert und das ganze Single Computing Systems Architecture, wie ist meine RPV, wie stellt sich das dem Anwendungsprogrammierer dar, das ist einfach immer noch von Hersteller zu Hersteller komplett verschieden.
Keine Einigkeit?
Keine Einigkeit, überhaupt gar nichts. Keine Ahnung.
Hat der Markt da nicht genug Druck oder hat diese Szene einfach nicht genug Einigungswillen?
Das liegt sicherlich natürlich an dem Einigungswillen, aber der Mangel der Einigungswillen kommt einfach aus der Schnelligkeit. Das ist nicht notwendig, dass man sich nicht einigen will. Das ist einfach so. So ein Standardsgremium ist einfach langsam. Die technologische Weiterentwicklung oder Feature XY ist einfach schnell mal ausgedacht. Das passt dann nicht mehr in den Standard rein, du kannst ja nicht mehr zurückgehen. Dann sagt man sich irgendwie, vergesst es bloß eine ganze Menge, Hersteller sagen von vornherein, interessiert uns nicht, brauchen das nicht standardisieren. Wir haben unseren Markt, wir sind die Größten, alle müssten sowieso nur unsere Produkte kaufen. Das ist ja weitverbreitetes Denken. Und so kommt es.
Das kennt man auch aus anderen Bereichen.
Und so ist dann der Fortschritt sozusagen aufgehalten.
Wie schlägt sich das denn so in dem Business? Bisher hat er immer noch zu Gange.
Ja, ich habe mich ja eine lange Zeit lang wirklich ausschließlich irgendwie mit Treiber-Interfaces zu ASR auseinandergesetzt.
Also Spracherkennung?
Spracherkennung, Spracherkennung, Text-Synthese, Sprecher-Identifikation und sowas. Da ist ja eine Zeit lang wirklich noch einiges passiert, im Moment ist es da allerdings auch relativ ruhig.
Also reden wir nochmal mehr über Anwendungen, auch wenn sicherlich dieser Telefonanlagenteil, den müssen wir uns auch nochmal anschauen, aber was wird denn, was kommt denn zum Einsatz? Also wird wirklich mit Spracherkennung, also mit Spracherkennung, I hate it, ja? Also seit ich denken kann, wann auch immer, ich will einfach nicht mit Computern reden. Geht dir das nicht genauso? Wenn sie einen Auftrag vermitteln wollen, dann sagen sie Auftrag und dann sieht man sich wirklich, wie man irgendwie so mitten auf so einem Bahnhofsvorplatz steht, irgendwie tausend Leute um einen herum oder was weiß ich, noch in der Warteschlange und dann wie so ein Blöder sagt man Auftrag in sein Telefon. Da weiß doch jeder, man ist irgendwie dumm, oder?
Ja, da gibt es eine recht schöne Anekdote dazu. Es gibt eine Organisation, die nennt sich Voice-Mail Association. Da sind die ganzen Leute drin, die Voice-Mail als Business-Modell haben und auch die Carrier. Also wirklich nur Leute, die Anrufbeantworter im Netz irgendwie als Hersteller oder als Carrier daran beteiligt sind. Die treffen sich ab und zu ein oder zwei Mal im Jahr an relativ hübschen Stellen. Und da war ich mal zufällig und da hat einer von der Telekom, die von T-Systems gerade war, der gerade ein Emotionserkennungssystem getestet hat, dann vorgetragen, wie das wäre mit dieser Emotionserkennung und das sei ja so und so. Dann wurde gefragt, ja, wie wird dann die Emotionserkennung getestet? Und daraufhin meinte er, ach, ärgerlich werden die Leute von selber. Das war leider der einzig gute Witz.
Es gibt Emotionserkennung.
Jaja, gibt es, gibt es.
Wie, wie, was? Welche Emotionen wollen die denn da erkennen?
Na hauptsächlich ärger.
Die wollen feststellen, wann die Leute verärgert sind?
Ja, damit sie frühzeitig einen menschlichen Operator durchleiten können. Es ist ziemlich perfide eigentlich.
Du meinst, sie sind ja, sie sind ja immer noch ganz gelassen und können wir sie auch noch mit einem neuen Menü nerven. Also du meinst, wenn man, wenn man irgendwo rein wählt und man kriegt dieses, wenn sie eins drücken, sie zwei drücken, sie drei oder sagen sie lalala, wenn man dann nicht sagt Operator, sondern wenn man sagt Operator, dann kommt ihr aus sofort?
Nein, das sind alles Prototypen, die auch soweit ich weiß, ist von denen noch keiner wirklich im Einsatz. Aber ja, das wird gemacht, darüber wird wirklich nachgedacht. Um das Ganze jetzt mal so ein bisschen in Schutz zu nehmen, auch kranken die meisten Dialoge daran, dass sie sehr, sehr lieblos gemacht sind. Es ist einfach immer noch wahnsinnig aufwendig, einen guten Sprachdialog zu machen.
Das stimmt.
Und die meisten machen sich die Mühe nicht. Und schlecht gemachte Sprachdialoge sind die absolute Pest. Ich muss zugeben, dass ich fast überhaupt keinen gut gemachten Sprachdialog kenne. Der einzige, den ich relativ gut fand, das war eine Zugauskunft, die Philipps mal gemacht hatte für die Deutsche Bahn. Das war bloß ein Prototyp, da haben die wirklich jahrelang dran gefeilt, sodass die Fragen auch so wunderbar suggestiv waren.
Die von damals? Das ist doch urlange her.
Das ist ewig her.
Das war die, wo man nur so bruchstückhaft sagen konnte, ich will nach Frankfurt, und dann wusste man schon etwas.
Genau. Und da gibt es dann ja die W3C, die hat dann was spezifiziert, dieses NLM nennt man das. Da bin ich jetzt aber auch gerade kurz mal draußen. Aber da ist dann so, du hast gesagt, ich will nach Frankfurt und hat das System erkannt, du willst nach Frankfurt und hat dann versucht, mit einem Slot-Filling-Algorithmus die restlichen Informationen in dem möglichst natürlichen…
Von wo reisen sie denn?
In dem möglichst natürlich strukturierten Dialog die fehlenden Informationen nachzufragen.
Und das man, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war das auch so, dass man gleich mehrere Informationen sozusagen einmal geben konnte, was man schon gesagt hat. Weil das ist eigentlich das, was die Leute so auf die Palme bringt. Das ist so, ich habe alles bereit, ich könnte dir alles sagen, wenn du mir nur zuhören würdest.
Ganz genau. Das konnte man da gut machen, wenn man gesagt hat, ich will nach Frankfurt fahren, dann hat man es gefragt, von wo wollen sie nach Frankfurt fahren? Und wenn du gesagt hast, ich möchte morgen um 17.43 Uhr in Frankfurt ankommen, von Berlin aus, dann hat es das auch hingekriegt. Aber das ist natürlich wirklich, wirklich aufwendig, weil da bist du darin, dass du wirklich gesprochene Sprache analysieren musst und da bist du wirklich an Dialogsystemen, die tatsächlich ein zumindest partielles Verständnis dessen haben, was ein Mensch so sagen kann. Und da, das ist ein weites und auch relativ interessantes Feld, auf dem sich in den letzten Jahren relativ wenig getan hat zum Anbetrauen.
Wie beunruhigend.
Das ist wahrscheinlich nur eine Frage der Zeit. Bei der Text-Synthese, das Gegenstück dazu, da hat es glaube ich 1996 den letzten richtig großen Durchbruch gegeben. Das war die Unit-Selection, damit sind die Computer-Stimmen sehr viel flüssiger geworden. Weil man mit dem erweiterten Speicherplatz auf den Festplatten dann angefangen hat, ganze Silben, ganze Worte gesprochen vorzuhalten und dann einfach nur noch aneinander zu stückelen.
Und das sind Systeme, die zum Beispiel auch bei den Versus komplett aus einzelnen Vornehmen zusammenzubauen.
Ja, oder komplett synthetisiert, also diese Capstra-Algorithmen, dieses, was wir am Anfang gehört haben. So in etwa klang ja die Sprachsynthesesysteme lange und das ist ja auch relativ weit vorbei. Also da auf dem Gebiet tut sich dann immer mal wieder was. Das ist dann einfach ein Durchbruch in der Forschung, der sich dann irgendwann später niederschlägt in neuen Produkten, in neuen Telefonanwendungen auch überhaupt. Das ist im Prinzip von der Forschung gesteuert und die Industrie tut da, ich sehe da wenig.
Vielleicht noch einmal zurück zu der ganzen API-Geschichte. Wir hatten es ja eingangs schon erwähnt, neben der jetzt ausführlich dargelegten, wie rede ich mit dem Telefonnetz-Technologie und wie spiele ich Sachen ab, wie nehme ich sie auf, Texterkennung und so weiter. Gibt es dann eben auch diese, ich sage es jetzt mal salopp, Telefonanlagen-Integration, dass man quasi schon davon ausgeht, das ist ja auch eine realistische Annahme, dass schon irgendein größerer Elektronik-Schrotthaufen rumsteht und in irgendeiner Form versucht, Telefonanrufe an den richtigen Menschen durchzustellen. Stichwort Call-Center halt, die das dann auch als Dienstleistung machen, da ist es natürlich ein ganz großes Thema, weil man da nicht immer nur feste Arbeitsplatznummern hat, sondern das eben so, je nachdem, wer von wo aus anruft und welche Nummer er dann angerufen hat und dann round Robin in einer Gruppe und so weiter, so eine Sachen, wo man dann aber sozusagen an dem jeweiligen Arbeitsplatz auch wissen will, was da vor sich geht, sodass du quasi die Telefonanlage mit einem reden musst. Das ist das, wovon wir sprechen. Und da kommen doch diese Sachen wie TAPI her, oder?
Genau, da kommen so Sachen wie die TAPI her.
TAPI ist die Telefon-API von Microsoft.
Von Novell ursprünglich. Ach wirklich? Jaja, von Novell. Die ist von Microsoft übernommen worden. Da kommt, damit kann man, TAPI kenne ich relativ wenig, das ist Anlagenfernsteuerung. Das wird natürlich auch viel benutzt in Call-Centern, ist aber auch darüber hinaus nützlich. Man darf ja nicht vergessen, selbst Leute, die wie ich sich schon seit wirklich fast 20 Jahren mit diesem Thema beschäftigen, sind eigentlich eher nur in Ausnahmefällen in der Lage, wirklich mal einen Anrufer weiter zu vermitteln von seinem Telefon aus. Ich meine, das kann einfach keiner.
Ich gebe es zu, dass ich sogar mit meiner Telefonanlage, ich habe auch Schwierigkeiten, das liegt aber daran, dass dieses Telefon, was ich hier habe, das hat keine R-Taste mehr.
Wir haben ja mal eine R-Taste genommen und an so etwas scheitert es auch. Für erweiterte Funktionen ein ziemlich schlechtes Benutzer-Interface und das kriegt man halt am Computer einfach viel, viel besser hin. Das stimmt. Das muss man einfach sagen.
Man könnte es unter Umständen viel besser hinbekommen.
Das kann man auf jeden Fall deutlich besser hinbekommen. Du kannst dann auch rechter Mausklick in Addressbook, Dial this person with my extension und dann geht der Anruf raus und du musst nur noch den Hörer abnehmen und dann kannst du auch mit drag and drop den einen Anrufer auf den anderen drauf ziehen und dann sieht das alles total super aus. Du kannst es wirklich auch verstehen, was da passieren soll. Das ist auch für größere Unternehmen interessant. Da wird das viel gemacht. Tarpi gibt es da, ich glaube J-Tarpi hatte noch einen deutlich breiteren Fokus. Die hatten auch Media-Processing da drin enthalten.
Also J-Tarpi ist die entsprechende Geschichte für Java?
Java, Telefonie, API. Genau, dann gibt es noch die CSTA, Computer-Supported Telecommunications Applications, genau, CSTA. Also das ist alles im Wesentlichen Anlagen, Fernsteuerung, Miterweiterung, eventuell auch für Media-Handling, dass man vielleicht auch mal einen Anruf terminieren kann und dann darauf DTMF erkennen kann und vielleicht auch noch einen Spracherkennner dazustöpseln kann, sowas in der Art.
Ist das dann auch alles Windows jetzt? Also klar, ich meine Java ist so bei Design nicht Windows, aber auch bei Java ist es ja so, die API allein macht ja noch keinen Sommer, sondern das sind ja nichts anderes als Frontend-Spezifikationen, wie ein Programm mit einem Subsystem redet, aber damit hast du noch kein Subsystem. Du brauchst ja etwas, was sich in diese API hineinimplementiert, bei Microsoft ist es selten anders. Was gibt es denn, sozusagen, ich meine, wenn ich mir jetzt nur eine Telefonanlage kaufe, dann wo kriege ich dann sozusagen meine Computer-Integration, meine CTI her?
Also CS der Aßen ist dankbarerweise ein Wire-Protokoll. Also auch gar keine API mehr, sondern wirklich ein Protokoll, das gibt es eine Spezifikation in ASN 1, es gibt eine Spezifikation in XML und da machst du wirklich einfach einen Socket auf, eine TCP-Verbindung auf zu deiner Telefonanlage, schickst dem eine Authentifizierung hin, die noch ein bisschen kompliziert ist und dann schickst du da einfach relativ simple XML-Objekte hin und her, Monitor Start, Make Call, XML formatiert, relativ süß und knack.
Aber das ist ja nur das Signaling, wie kriege ich das Audio dahin?
Ja, CSDA befasst sich ja mit dem Audio nicht.
Also für Audio …Das ist sozusagen nur so eine Markel-Schnittstelle. Also ich kann sozusagen meiner Telefonanlage oder meiner Endstelle sagen, was es tun soll. Es gibt …Anstatt die Telefon-Tastatur zu verwenden sozusagen.
Es gibt so in etwa anhand der …so am Rande dieser Verwerfungslinien IVR versus CTI, also das Behandeln von Anrufen, das direkte Sprechen mit Leuten oder zumindest das Vorspielen von Prompts für Leute und dem Fernstehen von Telefonanlagen gibt es zwei verschiedene Sichtweisen. Also in diesen beiden Camps gibt es zwei verschiedene Sichtweisen. Die eine ist First-Party-Call-Control. Das sind Leute, die sagen, ein Call ist das, was mir, ich bin der Endpunkt und die andere Seite, der andere Teilnehmer ist, das ist ein Call. Das ist First-Party-Call-Control.
Und wenn man selber was will am Anfang, ist es ausführlich dein Betrag.
Genau, wenn du das intrinsisch betrachtest.
Ich bin das Telefon.
Du bist das Telefon. Du guckst in deine Röhre rein, du schickst irgendwas rein und dann kommt tatsächlich das Freizeichen. Dann wählst du und dann kommt irgendwie jemand an die Leitung. Und dann gibt es Start-Party-Core-Control, das ist die Sicht von oben, die sagt irgendwie hier ist Endgerät A, die ist in Switching-Domain B und dazwischen ist Switching-Domain C und D und da ist Teilnehmer E und die werden dann miteinander verbunden und so von oben so ein Versteher. Weil es hat sich in dieser ganzen Stadt...
Und dieses CSTA, ich meine, spricht das jetzt?
Start-Party-Core-Control.
Ja, aber wer spricht denn das?
Telefonanlagen. Und alle? Das ist eine Sache.
Also wenn ich heute eine Telefonanlage kaufe, eine große im Sinne von mindestens 30 Plätze oder so.
Also es gibt auch kleine, die das unterstützen. Aber das ist geheim. Weil da gibt es auch was. Also normalerweise...
Was ist geheim?
Ich habe irgendwie Hardware auf meinem Tisch rumliegen, kann ich nicht von reden.
Okay, also es gibt im zunehmenden Maße, also die Aussage ist, es ist ausreichend populär, dass es die Wahrscheinlichkeit besteht, dass man das auch in kleineren Telefonanlagen demnächst sieht.
Genau, wenn es das nicht teilweise schon gibt. Ich glaube, Taki-Schnittstellen gibt es schon für...
Und das macht IP?
Das macht IP, genau.
Das heißt, man muss dann schon irgendwie in die Konfiguration dieser Telefonanlage reingehen und das dann erstmal mit dem eigenen IP-Netz verheiraten, IP-Adressen, da übliche Schnaß. Aber wenn das dann mal durch ist, dann hat man dann auch wirklich Endpunkte. Dann braucht man sozusagen nur noch die CSTA-Anwendung.
Genau.
Die gibt es bestimmt nur unter Windows.
Oder? Das ist ja egal.
Das ist egal, aber gibt es was? Gibt es so fertige Sachen zum Kaufen, so mit irgendwie läuft auf Linux oder...
Läuft auf Mac, ja gibt es. Wirklich?
Das heißt, also ist es wirklich absehbar, dass CSTA sich da noch ein bisschen breiter macht und sozusagen die Third-Party-Core-Control-Schnittstelle ist, die hat auch keine Konkurrenz? Oder gibt es noch was anderes?
Nicht wirklich, glaube ich, ach, da bin ich so ein bisschen aus meiner Wassertiefe raus, weil es deutlich mehr Funktionalität hat als Tarpi. Also Tarpi gibt es auch noch und Tarpi wird es auch wohl noch eine ganze Weile geben, aber das hat einfach weniger Features, dann kannst du weniger machen. Du kannst mit Tarpi kein Callcenter abbilden und mit CSDA kannst du das noch was machen, irgendwie etwa so.
Und vor allem Tarpi ist halt wirklich nichts anderes als eine API. Also es ist halt wirklich, man braucht dann sozusagen Software oder ist in Schimpf, ne? Also man braucht sozusagen Software, die Tarpi implementiert, um dann mit der eigenen Telefonanlage zu reden.
Ja, wobei es da auch eine Wire-Protokoll-Komponente geben muss, weil du die spezifizieren musst. Also Microsoft hat die Tarpi übernommen und macht die, glaube ich, versucht die auch noch weiter populär zu machen und da gibt es natürlich nach oben eine API, die Tarpi eben, aber die Schnittstelle zu den Telefonanlagen muss natürlich trotzdem spezifiziert sein. Und zwar auf dem Draht. Egal auf welchem Draht und egal wie, aber die muss spezifiziert sein. Die kenne ich bloß einfach nicht. Also das muss es geben.
Ja, wie läuft denn das so weiter? Gibt es auch dieses CSTA für Sachen wie Asterisk, Software-Only-Lösungen, die jetzt als Telefonanlagen mit VoIP und so weiter arbeiten?
Das gibt es nicht. Das könnte es theoretisch geben. Das ist aber natürlich ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Wer heutzutage irgendwie eine Voice-Applikation machen will, irgendwie seinen Freunden einen lustigen Anrufveranworter vorspielen will, wer irgendwie seine Current iTunes-Playlist unbedingt als Wartemusik haben muss auf seiner Telefonanlage oder was auch immer, der installiert sich einen Rechner mit Asterisk drauf und macht dann alles mit Voice-Over-IP und ZIP und RTP. Und die neueren Telefonanlagen, die dann CSDR zum Beispiel haben, haben deswegen ein Ethernet-Interface, weil die sowieso Voice-Over-IP können müssen, weil ISDN im Prinzip im Moment gerade runtergefahren wird. Ich glaube, die Deutsche Telekom hatte mal Pläne bis 2009, wird also nichts werden, das komplette TDM-Netzwerk intern abzuschalten und durch Voice-Over-IP ersetzt zu haben. Das wird nächstes, glaube ich, jetzt 2011.
Steht an. Genau. Dazu in einem baldigen Podcast mehr. Das Thema ist hier schon, braucht ihr da eins zu hinterfragen.
Schon vergehend.
Ja, aber hier wollten wir uns ja so ein bisschen auf den Endpunkt beschränken. Ja, weiß nicht, haben wir jetzt noch irgendwas Wesentliches unerwähnt gelassen, was man so in dem Zusammenhang noch erwähnen sollte? Also ich meine, welche, wenn man jetzt heute eine Anwendung machen will. Also angenommen, man will jetzt selber, was weiß ich, sich so eine lustige Villa zusammen bauen, wie wir das damals gemacht haben. Wer jetzt nicht weiß, wovon ich rede, muss man uns noch mal kurz erläutern. Also wir haben ja Anfangs der 90er Jahre dann eben einen Teil dieser hier auch schon erwähnten Technologien verwendet, um da so eine kleine lustige Abenteuerlandschaft zu bauen, wo man eben nicht mit Menüs rumhangelt, sondern das Ganze eben so auf diesem Adventuregedanken basiert, dass man immer irgendwo ist und dann überall eben irgendwelche Kommandos geben kann. Das war alles ganz spaßig. Solche Advanced-Anrufbeantworter könnte ja Leute auch reizen. Mein Telefon ist nach wie vor so ein doch sehr verbreitetes Endgerät und nicht alles lässt sich mit Internet so elegant machen, wie man das mit Telefon macht, allein schon weil es eben mit jedem Telefon zusammenarbeitet, auch wenn das von dem Internet nichts weiß. Was würde man denn dann heute nehmen? Was ist denn so die günstigste Möglichkeit, um mit ESDN oder so zu arbeiten? Also gibt es irgendwelche Software-Subsysteme, die einem schon solche Audio-Geschichten weitgehend abnehmen?
Ja, die gibt es. Das ist Astorisk zum einen. Und dann gibt es da auch noch ein paar Konkurrenten von Astorisk. Yet another Telefonie-Engine. Das sind, ja, also Astorisk ist eigentlich gedacht als Telefonanlage. Man kann damit aber auch noch mehr machen. Ist allerdings relativ stark limitiert, weil die alles, auch die ganzen IVR-Commandos in ihren Dialingplan reingesetzt haben, sodass man da relativ schwierig wirklich komplizierte Voice-Applikationen zusammenbauen kann. Da ist man Meteate besser bedient, das ist ein deutlich modulares System, das im Prinzip so eine Microkernel-Architektur so grob hat, also lose gekoppelte Komponenten. Es gibt einen geteilten Message-Bus und du kannst jetzt einen Prozess starten, der bekommt dann auf dem Standard-Innen die Audiodaten, wie sie reinkommen, Standard-Out, was du ausgibst, geht dann zum Hörer und da kannst du beliebig komplizierte Sachen machen. Mit Software Sound-Effekte über deinen Hintergrund laufen lassen, Mission-Konferenzen laufen lassen, Echo-Cancellation, selber rechnen, da kannst du alles machen, was du machen willst.
Und da gibt es auch kompatible Hardware für, dass man damit...
Die ist relativ günstig, da gibt es kompatible Hardware für, die auch relativ günstig ist. Die ist relativ weit vorne, diese ganzen Digium-Karten, da kostet ein Primär-Multiplexer immer noch ein paar Hundert Euro, aber jetzt nicht tausende, sondern nur ein paar Hundert. Das kann man machen, wobei man heutzutage wahrscheinlich sowieso alles über VoIP machen würde, also SIP und RTP. Ich habe bei mir zu Hause bereits ein Megabit Uplink, da kriegt man ein paar Anrufer drüber. Downlink sowieso 16 Megabit, aber das Uplink 1 Megabit. Mit dem Paket Overheads von RTP kriegst du acht Leute, da kriegst du glaube ich schon drei mit etwas aggressiveren Codecs, vielleicht sogar noch mehr. Aber wenn man jetzt so ein 30er Block wie beim ISDN PMX bedienen will, dann holst du dir ein Rechner im Hosted Server, im Rechenzentrum, lässt das da laufen, im Backborn, so wie du deine Internet-Anwendung auch laufen lässt, sobald du Bandbreite brauchst, ab ins Rechenzentrum damit, dann läuft dein Linux drauf und...
Also nichts spricht mehr gegen Voice-over-IP? Sind wir jetzt sozusagen an dem Punkt angekommen, wo das... Du musst mal ja fragen.
Ja, ich werde den Lauf der Dinge nicht aufhalten können. Ich bin von Voice-over-IP als Kunde relativ unbegeistert. Erstens krank, das überall funktioniert nirgends. Und zweitens hat Voice-over-IP ein paar intrinsische Nachteile gegenüber der guten alten Telefonie. Und der erste und wesentliche intrinsische Nachteil ist die Latenz, also die Verzögerung. Das Mindeste, was du theoretisch haben kannst, ist überhaupt die Zeit, die es dauert, ein Paket zusammenzusammeln. Weil du die Daten nicht kontinuierlich übertragen kannst, musst du erstmal warten, bis ein Paket voll ist. Das sind normalerweise schon mal 20 Millisekunden. Das ist eine Verzögerung, die schon deutlich über dem liegt, was im deutschen Telefonenetz irgendwie üblich war. Da hast du die 10 Millisekunden kaum überschritten. Dann kommt noch die ganze Latenz des Netzwerks dazu. Die ist ziemlich erheblich. Also wir reden da so von...
Und vor allem nicht konstant.
Und nicht konstant. Das heißt, dann gibt es noch die Jitterbuffer, die die nicht konstant des Delays versuchen auszugleichen, sodass wir bei End-to-End-Delay von mehr als 100 Millisekunden im Normalfall im Moment eigentlich ausgehen müssen. Und das ist keine so gute Qualität mehr in dem Sinne, dass das Telefonieren nicht nur dadurch ausgemacht ist, dass ich spreche und du mich hören kannst, sondern auch, dass du mir ins Wort fallen kannst. Das ist der wesentliche Punkt dabei.
Soll ich dir mal ins Wort fallen?
Das kannst du zufrieden haben. Das Problem ist, wenn du eine hohe Latenz hast, man kennt das, wenn man früher über einen Satellit nach Amerika angerufen hat, dann hat man geredet und geredet und plötzlich ist einem irgendjemand ins Wort gefallen, aber man konnte damit überhaupt nicht umgehen, weil es gibt so ein Protokoll, für das sich ins Wort fallen, das zwischen den Menschen so vereinbart ist. Man macht das normalerweise in einer Gesprächspause. Und diese Gesprächspausen sind halt nicht besonders lang. Man fällt dem anderen nicht ins Wort, während er gerade wirklich voll redet, sondern man wartet, bis er eine kurze Pause macht. Jetzt soll es ihm ins Wort fallen.
Die habe ich jetzt bewusst ungenutzt gelassen.
Und wenn diese Pause abläuft und die ist halt nur so 40, 50, keine Ahnung, Millisekunden lang, oder 100 vielleicht, dann kann man sich nicht mehr gut ins Wort fallen. Und dann wird es wirklich wie CP-Funk. Der eine spricht zu Ende, sagt Roger, und dann spricht der andere.
Es wird nie wieder so sein, wie es vor 20 Jahren war.
Das ist was anderes. Wobei natürlich der Ausbau des Internets voran geht. Die Ping-Zeiten werden immer kürzer. Ich war neulich komplett platt, als ich festgestellt habe, dass eine Ping-Laufzeit von meinem Heimnetzwerk zu google.de bei unter 20 Millisekunden lag. Da dachte ich, da hat wohl jemand einen Upgrade gemacht. Wo war es vorher? Ich war schon so bei 90.
Da habe ich noch nie so angeschaut.
Das interessiert mich, weil das die Latenz beeinflusst. Und damit auch die Gangbarkeit von Wolfgang Weiging.
Über Latenz mussten wir nicht sagen. Latenz ist auch der Feind des Podcasters. Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich...
Analoges Equipment.
Erstens das und zweitens, warum ich auch das direkte Gespräch immer bevorzuge gegenüber irgendwelchen über Skype oder haste nicht gesehen, gerade weil das eben einfach nicht funktioniert. Theoretisch könnte man halt das Telefon machen. Da kommt natürlich noch der andere Aspekt mit sich nicht sehen und so weiter. Das ist ja auch noch mal eine gewisse Latenz, die da sozusagen noch mit dazu kommt. Aber das ist halt Voice-over-IP, ich sehe das genauso. Das ist einfach ein Drama.
Momentan ist es ein deutlicher Rückschritt.
Noch ist es ein Drama.
Es ist erst mal ein deutlicher Rückschritt und es wird für die nächsten Jahre ein deutlicher Rückschritt bleiben. Und es wird auch so sein, dass die Leute ganz normal eine Telefondose bei sich zu Hause verkauft bekommen. Da schließen die ganz normal ihre analogen Telefone an. Und hinter dieser Dose läuft dann alles über Voice-over-IP und sie haben die ganzen Nachteile ohne irgendeinen Vorteil.
Gut, ich denke, Lars, wir haben es jetzt eingepackt hier. Das war Chaosradio Express zum Thema Computer- und Telefonie-Integration. Und ja, es soll weitergehen. Ich habe es schon angedeutet, hier mit Telefonie-Themen. Das ist eher eine günstige Fügung als Generalstabs-mäßig geplant. Aber mal gucken, vielleicht rede ich jetzt auch schon wieder über irgendwas, was dann im letzten Moment dann doch wieder scheitert. Von daher halte ich mich noch bedeckt. Aber ihr seid eingeladen, auch weiterhin zuzuhören, hier bei Chaosradio Express. Und ihr seid auch eingeladen, das mal weiter zu erzählen. Bloggt doch mal. Es wird immer viel gehört, aber es wird immer nicht so viel gebloggt. Also wenn ihr irgendwie über solche Schreibmedien verfügt, dann würde ich mich freuen, auch mehr darüber zu lesen, wie ihr Chaosradio Express findet. Und nicht nur als direktes Feedback. Das ist natürlich auch gewünscht, wie immer. Gern gesehen, Kommentare im Blog. blog.chaosradio.ccc.de Oder wenn es was ganz Intensives gibt, was ihr ja nicht in einem Blog mitteilen wollt, dann auch Feedback an chaosradio.ccc.de per E-Mail. Ja, das war so mein Standard abgesungen. Vielen Dank, Lars. Und dann sagen wir noch schön Tschüss von den Hörern. Und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.